Kristen Stewart knows a little bit or
actually a lot of it about box office
success remember those little Twilight
movie out there guys remember them yeah
it's our upcoming role though in the new
Charlie's Angel that has her using some
big screen muscle Aditi on lines lauren
zima found out I've been boxing a little
bit which I've never done was so
addicted to it as soon as I have to
actually start sparring though and I
realize that what I'm doing is is
intended to plank fight people I'm like
dude I it like it really is like
assaulting and I hate it I really hate
it Lucy Liu told us this is just gonna
be such a positive reboot to happen for
women of course why do you think now is
the right time
oh that's really cool that she said that
um it's true I think it it's um not
maybe everyone's immediate response that
it would be like something that we would
need to see again because the one that I
grew up with is so much fun but we're
not trying to sort of we're not doing an
impression of the last one exactly which
angel Kristen will be a still a tightly
kept secret but remember her breakout
role as Bella in Twilight that was ten
years ago this November she was just 17
when she was cast and it made her an
instant star people asked me for my
phone number quite a bit and it was sort
of like make me feel song I'm just like
uh I would I can't I can't
it's funny I've also lived in the same
neighborhood for ten years and I thought
that the other day and I was like oh god
I was like you know a decade ago wasn't
as crowded and I was like that's bizarre
Kristen's new movie Lizzy will be
hitting theaters next month co-starring
Chloe Sevigny it's a retelling of the
infamous true crime story of Lizzie
Borden accused of murdering her father
and stepmother with max do you watch
your binge any of those true crime shows
when I do I always regret it afterwards
because I don't sleep well because I
watched three hours of like murder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]